you tell me what i can't say you're
sensing what i can
you say i'm offensive because i believe
my eyes and i say i see a woman not a
man
you call me thick and racist for not
wanting to be a part of a rich man's
club in europe or a globalist new world
daughter with no
soul or guts or heart you throw at me
the slave trade
you tell me my five-year-old grandson is
to blame you point your brandon accusing
intolerant fingers and told me to hang
my head in shame
i'm free to have opinions as long as
they fall in line with yours
i can fly my banners high and proud as
long as you support that cause
you have to be right all the time yours
is the only way
i have to like the things you like be
there black trans left or gay
it makes no difference if i tell you i'm
not the things for which you accused
because once you've made up your closed
off minds
i'm always going to lose i have black
friends so you're still a racist
homophobic but i've shared beds with gay
men
i'm an anti-say mind but the rothschilds
is the richest banking family in this
world and that's got nothing to do with
them being jewish and everything to do
with them being multi-billionaires
really can influence the dollar pound in
yen
you sip your pinot grigio in trendy bars
down in the smoke
looking down your noses with loathsome
contempt of billions of working-class
fork
well i've come here to tell you that you
have had your time because the winds
have changed are blowing and bills of
freedom symbols
goes my glass my [ __ ] class
is waking up and staring and we're going
to peacefully attack
we're going to breach those pc walls of
segregation that have divided gay
straight white and black
i've got no malice in my heart i don't
judge people
on the sex or creed or race i don't
speak a lot of absolute [ __ ] behind the
back
not even the bloke who murdered me dad i
just tell them to the face
so to all you brandon liberals who want
a loud debate
i hate no man or woman i just want the
right to hate
i want the right to hate like i want the
right to love
i want to like and dislike what i want
to like and dislike and be able to
vocalize it bro
i'm not responsible for slavery and i'm
not taking any blame because the white
privilege
built on black slavery you say that i
enjoy well
beyonce jay-z oprah winfrey rihanna
floyd mayweather alicia keys jimmy fox
barack obama at all all enjoyed the same
beyonce spent 87 million dollars in a
house just through shaking the ass while
maina would last say that all lamenting
about ways to pay the [ __ ] gas
and i don't see too much white privilege
in a system that lets east european
immigrants or wounded soldiers live in
cardboard and boxes why do black lives
matter and progressives fail to see
not all white folks live in stately
homes chasing [ __ ] foxes
i'm not homophobic transphobic or
anything phobia you can see because i
don't fear sex
or race agenda i just won't bow down to
your pc
don't confuse my use of slang with
racism and bigotry
don't confuse my rejection of your shite
with spite
don't naturally assume i'm thick and
racist because i'm northern working
class i'm not
i'm articulate sharp and bright and i
will not walk a minefield every time i
open my mouth to speak
and i will not apologize for things i've
glibly said or spoken tongue-in-cheek
so shape up or [ __ ] off with your
madness because i'm going to bring you
down
i'm going to bring working-class people
together muslim
christian white and brown i'm going to
bring those globalist walls of jericho
crashing on your brainwashed liberal
feet
and i'm going to blow my loving
inclusive on pc
fanfare and your communist fascist
capitalist socialist left right
catholic protestant muslim christian
black white
gay straight male female
leave remain against kova 19
four kov 19 against vaccinations four
vaccinations
democratic republican north south
divides i will defeat
you divided us the working classes
and you've conquered us and you've
[ __ ] laughed at us
at the top so i've come to my mates
program to tell you
right now to this camera it's time for
your [ __ ]
to [ __ ] stop
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is one of our
favorite comedians working
in the uk today who finds himself in the
spot of bother chris mcglade welcome to
trigonometry all right lizard we're
doing all right
it's good to have you man uh uh we have
known you for a while and you and i
particularly go back a long way
but uh tell everybody who doesn't know
you who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
well um basically i've been a comedian
for 33 years i um
and for most of that time i've been a
working men's club comedian
and uh worked on the in the social clubs
in and around the north all over the
north of england
but i have had four years into the
comedy circuit
you know over the years and i've done
that under my own steam you know
and i don't know how these people on
that
in the main middle class progressive
kind of like comedy circuit take me i've
always tried to amalgamate both styles
of
of humor really so i've got this like
unique
approach and um and i do that not only
in the middle class
circuit here in london on the comedy
circuit but also in those working men's
clubs so i've been
doing that um for some time now it's a
great effect and my polit
my comedy's become more political over
the last 11 or 12 years
in particular because i fought a
political campaign in red car
that was totally corrupted really um we
exposed all kinds of things and changed
the law
in this uh in this country regarding
open spaces and
after that it was it was kind of like
my comedy when i'd seen like the level
of of corruption and things locally
my comedy had to reflect that if you
know what i mean i had to start speaking
out
about things that i i felt were [ __ ]
and um and like i say i've tried to do
that
in that middle class comedy circuit
style but i've always
tried to stay true to my working men's
club
roots and that quick you know one line
the style of
of comedy and um i know i don't work
very much
[Laughter]
but uh i guess i've never been in comedy
for the
for the money john i've never certainly
been one that's i mean i
appreciate i've got to make a living but
it's always been the love of it and
over the last 11 years also it's
it's wanting to see things if you know
what i mean
that that i think
stinks and uh and i've been trying to do
that more
more and more over over the years you
know and it's but like it's here 32
years
well 33 years this year i've been a
comedian and when i met you
a friend mutual friend of ours when we
were at a dead umbrella festival
uh at the same time i didn't know who
you were i went to see you
uh in the caves yeah you had this
massive room it was 120 seater i think
big and the day i saw you there was nine
people in
one row and i sat there watching for an
hour played to nine people i think two
of them were german tourists he couldn't
understand a word
and i came back again because that's how
good it was
and that's the thing that you do is you
combine
as you say good jokes really good funny
jokes
you hate political correctness and you
talk about the political things that are
happening in the world today
yeah yeah i mean i just i'm i'm trying
to
what i've always wanted to do is i've
always wanted to bring both sides of
comedy together
so like i think at the moment comedy's
too
imbalanced it's too hot uh top heavy in
one direction
the whole of the industry these days is
controlled
by middle-class progressive kind of
people
whether it be agents whether it be
promoters
bookers the comedy club circle certainly
and and i've been trying to like even
things up
to a certain degree if you know what i
mean um by
by bringing working class traditional
working class humor
into these places but mixing it with the
kind of humor that you would find
in the comedy club because i think
working class comedians
um of working men's club comedians they
never
they never get a look when was the last
time you saw wigan men's club comedian
nano stacks a lads on the circuit who
were really funny men
and they would never get a look in live
on the apollo or any of these kind of
game shows or panel shows or whatever
gentlemen because because they're not
they don't put forward the humor they
don't do the humor that these people who
control comedy like and and it's it's a
discrimination in the way for me
it is a discrimination what and why do
you think it is chris that they don't
want to
put these types of comedians on telly
and all the rest of it because they
don't like them that's as simple as that
you know it's like it's like it's like
the people who control comedy
they have their perceptions of what
comedy should be
and it isn't what's in the working men's
clubs they think it's happening it's all
dating and perhaps it is
but it appeals to millions and millions
and millions of people
enjoy them i mean i'm listen i mean i
wear this on the shamely all the time
right
i've got like loads of t-shirts that's
here working class man i'm absolutely
proud of my class
right and i'm even more proud of my
class by virtue of the fact
that we don't get a seat at the table
journal main
and and everything is controlled by this
middle-class
like progressive mindset and
when i sit in the club or when i sit in
the pub with the lads
they'll say oh do you see that comedian
and they tell you [ __ ] rubbish you
know
didn't understand him knowing what he
talked about it wasn't even funny and
they said
see these people control comedy you put
these comedians on the television
because they like them but they're not
they don't necessarily have broad appeal
and i'm not slagging any comedian off
i'm just saying
it's wrong that it's only one kind of
comedy that's been fostered on the
public of this country
time and time and time again because
there are millions of working class
people
right who love the comedians who go in
the working men's clubs
and yet they're in comedy isn't catered
for
on television or or anything else you
know
and and i just i think i try to be a bit
of a trojan artist
really taking one set one kind of humor
into a comedy club and taking on the
comedy club because it's a flip thing
with me because i always try and
take that middle class comedy kind of
comedy that i don't
i try and take that into the working
men's clubs or in the sportsman's dinner
too gentlemen so it's balanced
but i can i can see i've been a comedian
for 33 years so i can
i can do different kinds of comedy if
you want me to be over the top i'll be
over the top if you want me to be clean
i'll be clean
and chris what would you say to those
people who like these middle class
liberals who go well hang on you know
you just want to go on stage you know do
bernie manning s
style jokes from the 1970s society's
moved on
and you need to accept that well i i
i it's not about doing bird and manning
style jokes
when you watch these guys in the
afternoon this vegan circuit you know
they are funny
guys they don't they don't do burning
manning style
material that once again it's like a
small-minded
view of these comedians you know it's
like i've said to a couple of
comedy critics when was the last time
you ever went into a working men's club
[Laughter]
and reviewed and reviewed and reviewed a
comedian when was the last time you
you you know and and they haven't up
there you know
and i just it's it's just the
discrimination and
and i i think that working class people
are discriminated
in lots of ways but especially
in comedy especially in comedy you can
get if you work in class and you
and you do the the style of comedy that
that you know everybody else does in the
in in the comedy clubs that's fine
but if you if you do that traditional
working-class kind of humor that appeals
to working-class people
you've got no chance well this is why i
was so happy because
i you know i i opened with the anecdote
about how you and i first met when
you you were having a rough time of it
in terms of getting audience in and it
wasn't easy even though your show was
brilliant
and you are a brilliant comic but last
time that edinburgh happened which is
2019 you did a show called forgiveness
which francis and i both saw which
was one of the best shows at the
festival
you got you sold out your room
you got brilliant reviews and it got
followed up with a run of the soho
theater
and you've been doing brilliantly on
that front
and as of a couple of weeks ago
you were supposed to get your run at
soho theater which is one of for people
out outside of the uk one of the biggest
theaters in london
certainly like a taste making kind of
theater here
um and that didn't happen
no well yeah they've got core feet
and um why is that well
i mean it's been been an oppressed to a
certain degree no i don't think i don't
think it's over
as far as the press goes but um
so i i wrote the show about my dad's
murder my dad was uh strangled and
set on fire in 2011.
and um and i more or less instinctively
forgave the man
who murdered him
i thought was the way to go i felt
that was right for me my father
was a very um forgiving person never
held any grudges also a very funny
person or
and completely on pc but big hearted
always big hearted
and um i mean i had some counselling and
so on and so forth and then we i
was when i was doing uh northern monkey
in edinburgh in 2018
i had this uh like panic attacking
and i ran off the stage i didn't know
what was going on really and
i go back to my digs and i wrote this
poem called blood beneath your nails and
i realized then
that there was stuff that uh that i had
to
exercise even though i'd had counselling
you know
and i thought myself well you know i'm a
comedian you know
this tell the story and i always
remember my mate wilson milton one of
the
lads on the circuit like you know i said
i'm gonna do this show about or dad's
murder
you know and he went wow why and i said
yeah uh he said i was gonna make it
funny i said i don't know yet but i'll
work on it like you know
so i i came back from edinburgh and i
started
to write just the stories the anecdotes
and once again i mixed it
with the traditional
working men's club quick one-liner jokes
that i've
i'm glad we've been doing for so many
years
and um i took it to edinburgh and as you
say
it just went off the scale like you know
every night apart from one
the first night but even then the times
came to see me on the first night
but after that first night it just went
through the [ __ ] roof
it was like you know there were like
queues like literally up three flights
of stairs or two flights of stairs and
out the city cafe and uh critically
acclaimed across the board
people were hailing it as a masterpiece
uh a master class in comedy
genius and all of this you know some
people were saying it's like it's like
one of the most important comedy shows
because it it didn't just address the
issue
of forgiveness and and tolerance and
everything else
it also addressed the issues of race
because you know
dad was from a very multicultural
uh area in middlesbrough and stuff you
know and
and it just it just swept the board at
edinburgh
and then this top promoter came to see
and he just said this is fantastic like
you know
never seen anything like it so
uh he got me in the soho theater and uh
just for people who don't understand
you've been at it for at this point for
30 years
well 32 years yeah and this is your
dream
coming true finally you're getting
recognition well you know what what it
was
this is the thing i thought was you see
because like gigs were few and far
between
right on the comedy comedy circuit for
the reasons i believe i
stated at the start topped the interview
and started the interview
so like when i got all this like acclaim
and everything and bearing in mind
i mean i've been to edinburgh three
times 17 18 and 19.
and every time i'd gone there i've been
like critically acclaimed across the
board but this was
mega critical acclaim you know yeah and
uh and it and it was like
it was like for me personally
that recognition was like seeing these
people who control comedy look
you know this is this is me
i felt so proud of that this is me as a
working men's club comedian
i've done i've this is this is the level
of my writing this is the level of my
comedy i can do what you do and i can do
or i can do what you want me to do and i
can do this in the work men's clubs i
can do this
and it i was so proud of myself at that
moment in time because
leading up to that the work had been so
non-existent really
i'd i'd felt many times like like just
jacking it all in of course when we went
into the soho theater
uh i mean that was just like everything
for me man you know i mean i mean
i mean the soho theater for anybody who
doesn't know out there is
so cutting edge you know they don't have
any shite in there
and uh and i was just i don't know about
that
well not well well i know i know i know
what you mean but
but in their eyes yeah yeah yeah you
understand right
they're not compromising on things they
get who they want to get exactly
yeah right yeah yeah and and like like
i'm just like floating on there and then
i got a call off
of uh off the promoter
and he said uh right um they want you
they really want you
because they can't see me never twice
you know
the programmer came to see me and then
this girl came to see me on the last
night and it was just wonderful and they
said they really want you
and i said okay that's brilliant yeah
but they want you to take something out
and what would i want to take out well
there's someone they don't want you use
the word [ __ ] and they don't want you to
use the word [ __ ] right so my first
instinct was
i said tell my [ __ ] off right
chris before you go any further just
give people a little bit of the context
because some people are hearing this for
the first time
i know you're working up to it but i'm
just saying this because some people
will make assumptions based on what
you've said
yeah you've said you're working class
comedian you said they didn't want you
to use those two words
and they're going to assume that you
were making fun of those
no not at all it was in context of the
it was the it was right it was in
the words were used in the context of
the 1970s you were telling a story about
your dad
yeah and the the the slang and the words
that were used
in working class communities
multicultural working class communities
in the 70s and stuff and out when i was
growing up with my father
so it was all in context right right and
and
we'd we'd like used or i'd use the words
in in edinburgh
and i'd stand innovations nobody
everybody
understood the context right i mean the
promoter all the comedy critics that
came and said they all knew it was in
context and everything else
it wasn't just like using it
gratuitously that's what i mean yeah it
wasn't it wasn't like that at all
so i should write okay my first instinct
was to tell my [ __ ] off because
because that's that's just me you know i
mean and and stuff so
and then and then i thought no okay then
right um
i mean i was broke and i needed a break
so i screwed my note and i said right
okay and i'll take the words out right
and i'll and i'll replace them but i'll
also
take the piss i'll i'll make fun of the
fact that i've been censored
and the promoter said that's fine right
anyway we went there
did the the four nights at the soho
theater last year
and i'd written this maybe his 15-minute
piece to to to put in the show and it
was all about
um working class mentalities
right on working class slang and working
class jokes and
working class humor and
how you can tell a joke and how you how
you can use slang words without actually
being
racist or whatever like you know
and uh and it worked just fantastically
i mean
the director of the theater came i mean
i had like four shows and i got four
standard innovations right
the director of the theater was there on
the friday night
and i did like an hour and 50 minutes
and i mean after the show it was
i i like floated down the stairs back
into the bar
and i always remember i was just leaving
the theater i was in the street and he
ran away in the street and said are you
coming back and i said well yeah i'll be
back here tomorrow night for me last
year and he said no
will you come back to the theater and do
like you know more shows i said well of
course well yeah
hey constantin how are you feeling good
and your mental health i'm from russia
we don't have mental health
well in the civilized world we talk
about our mental health
and how we're feeling about our place in
the universe
in the words of my uncle vlad that is
why we will crush you
well he's two months away from a
breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm
that helps you to negotiate the tricky
modern world
it's okay to need help sometimes and
calm can provide support
calm has been really useful for me you
can clear your head with
guided daily meditations improve your
focus with calms curated music tracks
and drift off to dreamland with calm's
imaginative
sleep stories narrated by soothing
voices
like killian murphy and stephen fry oh
killian save me
man up drink vodka feel better if you go
to calm.com
trigger you'll get a limited time offer
of 40
off a calm premium subscription
which includes hundreds of hours of
programming and new content is added
every week over 1 million people around
the world use calm
to take care of their minds yes
trigonometry fans get special limited
time promotion 40
off premium subscription take advantage
of this amazing offer go to khan.com
forward slash trigger
for 40 off unlimited access to calm
entire library that's calm dot com
forward slash trigger
and uh anyway i finished the run and the
number was just off the scale
you know it was like just everything i
mean i like that working men's club
humor
it was it was it had the the middle
class
like political kind of observational
kind of stuff generally
it had poetry in it it was also
done in a way of telling a story it was
just everything
and after the run uh the promoter came
back and he said well
you know they were just blown away by it
and they said you know they want you to
go
and um on an extended run
in june um in the main theater part i
think or the
uh exclusive cabaret room that they've
got there
and um and and they want to co-produce
the show
i think the one in the co-producer tour
they wanted to film it and put it on
pay-per-view and all this and the other
you know blah blah blah
and it was just i was i remember the
morning i got the call i was
i was in this cafe in redka and
the promoter for me and i just i brought
down and cried because it was
it was just everything i mean i'd
actually
i'd actually been recognized by
the establishment if you know what i
mean this establishment that never lets
comedians like me in
right had recognized me
and my worth as a comedian
and that meant everything to me
that meant the world to me
if i didn't make a penny for the shores
and i didn't make any money in edinburgh
and i didn't make any money from the
first sawhort either one
but if i never made a penny from the the
run that they wanted me to do
it wouldn't have made a [ __ ] blind
bit of difference to me
because these people are that mindset
that man it's not people it's the
mindset that tried to keep me out or
had kept me out that said we think
you're the dog's bollocks
and and it just it was just everything
to me
it was 32 years of being billed off
paired off
i had paint glasses through on it yeah
[ __ ] challenged with knives
just everything you know echoed the
whole lot
and then i was this establishment that
that this mindset that controls comedy
and said
we think you're great and they said to
the promoter here um we had people
coming at this theater
that nobody that we've never had before
and promotion would you mean working
class people
and he went yeah yeah
i felt like brave art you know william
they're coming down from the hills in
the hundreds
they were coming down from [ __ ]
newcastle and were coming over from
south yorkshire they came down from
nottingham from clubs where i'd been in
nottingham all my life
they were coming over from wolverhampton
up from the up from the
the southwest they were coming from all
over the place
and i thought and just to see me in the
soho theater
and uh and that just meant the absolute
world and
i mean i played the comedy store in
hollywood
and i played on the main stage and this
massive room years ago
2003 2004 and i had to call because my
mom was dying
um of her heart was she had a attack but
she had heart failure
and cancer and stuff and and so that
ended that one
you know i mean and then um
and then i was in billy elliot in the
west end
uh in the victoria palace theater
biggest break to date
and the old fellow was murdered and that
really
after that you know they put me in a
room at the top of the theater so my bad
vibes didn't like rub off on any of
the rest of the cast which is fair
enough um
and that was the end of that one really
but like this one
it was like well nothing's going to stop
me now not nothing possibly can stop me
because i know my own word
i say i have very low self-esteem
because you know i'm like
that's just being bullied as a child
really but like
i i know i've got what it takes as a
comedian you know
and um and i thought nothing's going to
stop it now
what couldn't stop it because he even
netflix were interested
you know hollywood film director well
he's a british film director but he's
directing hollywood movies and he's with
robert de niro and all this he wanted to
write a screenplay
you know there was a canadian tv company
a
canadian stroke north american tv
company wanted to do
a series about me on on the theme of
forgiveness one i think they wanted me
to go around north america talking to
people who suffered murder like me and
discussed
with them people or the victims of
murder discuss the the
the concept of forgiveness you know
and like two weeks after bump knocked
down everything stops
got it absolutely good been gutted ever
since
i mean that's very understandable just
uh and particularly
lockdown everything stops but then we
fast forward
and you've got your your run at the soho
yeah yeah well you see the thing is i i
i kept in touch with with the the
director of the theater
he said in august you know you
definitely know mixing stuff and then
never read anymore
and then i let go of myself like you
know i've
when we i'd had these two shows planned
uh of forgiveness in my own town in red
car
and it was like 1990 tickets uh for the
shore
i mean at first you're just gonna be one
show and then
uh it sold out within an hour
and then so we put and we put another
shine and then that's all by the
following day
and there was people flying over from
ireland and flying up from
bristol and they were coming down from
newcastle and and were coming up from
the midlands
all to come to the red carpet see the
show there was even two women from
america
said if we could get a flight we'd come
and fly over from america
to see the shore and i'm like wow
and then locked on was called again and
not just like
just like finished me off really i
started drinking like loads let myself
go
didn't clean the house you know what i
mean just
completely let myself go grow a massive
beard
just wasn't bothered wasn't interested
you know and then i got a call
and about the end of january and this
and the promoter said you know
the theater says she's still in the mix
that's great and so on and so forth and
so
you know we'll be getting some dates so
and then that's great
course nothing came month weeks went by
weeks went by we shouldn't buy
nothing and then um
[Music]
maybe about six or seven weeks ago now
six weeks ago
got a call and said oh the promoter said
basically uh
they need to talk to you and i said why
and they said because the
thing your show is anti-semitic so i
said right okay
what aren't you submitting like they
said well somebody's alerted them to
your poem the right to hate so i said oh
okay then
see in the right to hate there's the
there's the
verse that says you know i've got black
friends so you're still a racist
homophobic but i've shared beds with gay
men i'm an anti-semite
but the rothschilds is the richest
banking family in the world you know
really can influence
and that's what nothing to do with them
being jewish and everything to do with
them being multi billionaires
really can influence the dollar pounding
yen
and that's the the verse that caused the
controversy it caused controversy last
year when it went when it when the poem
went viral i mean the poem went virally
like tens of millions of people
now i understand the anti-semitic trope
you know that like uh zion zionists and
ross charles and all that you know
control world banking and that's what
hitler
based his his attack on you know before
the war and all of this
but my that section of the poem wasn't
about that at all
my that section of my poem
was about the middle class
or in the main middle class progressive
liberal
mindset versus the working class
mindset because
in my working-class existence with my
working-class friends
they don't understand or you can be
racist and have a black wife
or a black husband or a black partner or
a black friend right
and they don't understand or you can be
homophobic
and have gay friends right and they
don't understand
how as the richest banking family in the
world
even though they're not as big a players
as they used to be how they
they can't influence stock markets
or currencies and that's what it was
about it was and that's what basically
what the poem is about
it's about
working with working class mentality
as opposed to that middle-class
progressive mentality
and it like it's like for me
that middle-class progressive mentality
is riding roughshod over everything
and it's not giving our mentality any
kind of
any kind of air time really
do you want a mine yeah i had this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
online right saying that you know he'd
put this post on facebook
and he described us as working people
i've noticed that coming in more and
more
over the years this this term working
people
very ambiguous working people and i i
responded to them i said hey mate
you missed the word out there and he
said have i and i said yeah you have
i said you missed the word class mate
right and he started going on the
[ __ ] quote in karl marx at me
save all your [ __ ] middle class
[ __ ] for me i said i don't give a
toss right i said
you have to have the word class and
basically what he was saying was
if you've got a job you work in class
[ __ ] prick
idiot right and this is what these
people don't get
right because working class people it's
not just about having a [ __ ] job
right we're with our own culture
we have a woman we are speaking we have
our own mindset we have our own thought
processes
you know we think differently
it's a culture working class is a
culture
white and black you know we go on old
days to different places
than than middle class people they even
smoke different [ __ ]
i said this in 2018 sure you know
working class people buy an agile smoke
embassy regal
oh my fair and and and middle class will
be smoking [ __ ]
marlborough jeremy and marvel late it's
it's
it's not just about having a job being
worked in class it's a culture
right and it's a mentality
and it's a mindset and i feel very
passionate about it
and it's getting completely completely
roared roofshot over
by this progressive in the main middle
class
mentality and it has to stop it has to
stop
because it's because it's discriminating
so much
and i don't give a flying [ __ ] if people
attack me online and say this not near
the right
but i will not stop championing my class
my culture no matter what color you are
because it's a it's a culture being
working class is its own culture
and that is what the right to hear is
about right
it's about our culture being dominated
by these people who tell us
you can say this but you can't say that
but you can say that but you can't say
this
and you will think that and if you and
if you don't know oh yes and then
the pre-judging that's what the whole
thing is you know what i mean you're
racist do you this you're that you're
the other well i'm sorry i'm not
because i left school with two or levels
you know well three levels one was in
english one was in that and one was in
[ __ ] trumancy
i'm not the best educated man over i i
left school at 16 years old my english
teacher when i was 14 said
humor glade or oxford or cambridge
material do you know that and i laughed
at him and i told him to [ __ ] off
right because he had these dead heads
behind me and he said to me first of all
don't tell me to [ __ ] off because you're
an english teacher
and second of all don't tell me to [ __ ]
off because you will have an experience
when your older son
and you will realize what i've said is
true
and i had that experience last year when
i wrote this poem called will she fly
and when i read it on this men's mental
health station radio station in
middlesbrough these guys
were like wow and that's when i had the
realization that yeah i was
oxford and cameras material actually
right but that wasn't my path
i went straight in with steel mill when
i was 16 years old
i was making you know my professors were
like ernie button and colin ali and
terry target lads we
worked in the mills and the cranes and
the stock tick and and the stock
uh yards and everything else jeremy they
were my professors they were my teachers
you know that was that was the the road
i went down
and so i've tried to educate myself over
the course of my life about different
things
and i might have said things that that
in the past have been anti-semitic or
racist but that's not because
out of malice because there's no malice
in me right that's out of ignorance
really and i've tried to learn as much
as i can
to put those things right do you
understand
okay yeah but but this
the whole poem is about
defending working class mentality and
culture
you know as opposed to this progressive
i'm not even going to say left because
it's not left it's centrist
they're not they're not they're not left
they're not the tradition i was a member
of the labour party when i was 17 years
old
you know what i mean signing on picket
lines and stuff
i'm like a proper traditional
working class socialist
but i don't identify with the left now
because it's not the too busy
branding people and using id politics to
shut people up and
do people down and all of that you know
and that's what the point was about but
being dominated by this
mindset that is completely alien to ours
and we're not allowed anywhere back at
all you know what i mean we're not
allowed anywhere back
it's a really really powerful point and
i'm so glad that we've got you on the
show to express that
there's something that i push back
against a lot because
it's the term white privilege and i feel
that it's used as against as a weapon
against working class people and
particularly working working-class men
to get them to shut up and not have an
opinion i can't
francis i listen my my family came from
ireland
my family were immigrants right
my family came from ireland at the turn
of the last century
i mean they were they were basically
land slaves
you know picking potatoes or just
working for a pittance you know i mean
like indentured labor
just like like nothing and they came
over here
i mean my uncle my auntie died of cancer
last year my uncle gave me some
photographs i go back to lake victoria
in terms of my family and
i cried when i saw them again i felt
this infinity to them straight away i
mean they're not like the peaky blinders
you know
me my great-great-granddad and his two
brothers are sat in his badge on the t's
and i [ __ ] broke down and cried this
is my blood
these men were [ __ ] working at fields
they hadn't read anything
they had [ __ ] all and they came in this
country with
[ __ ] all and i've got [ __ ] all
nothing and i and and those people
those people had no privilege whatsoever
they were irish catholics and they would
and they were regarded as being [ __ ] you
saw the signs in restaurants didn't
there
no blacks no dogs no blacks and no cat
no irish
and and that's that was the thing they
were it was the same kind of thing
so i don't go with all that white
privilege [ __ ]
jeremy privilege isn't about your colour
it's about how much money you have
that's what sets you apart that's what
gives you privilege
i mean i love marcus rashford i think
mark was
what marcus rashford has done for
working class kids in this country is
exactly right it's it's fantastic the
lad
for me the lad should be he should get a
gong or a knighthood or whatever
because he's trying to champion
working-class children but do you think
if he wasn't a multi-millionaire center
forward from manchester united in
england
that he would have got to boris johnson
or being listened to
he would have just been another [ __ ]
squad living in manchester wouldn't he
nobody would have listened to him it's
not about you your color it's about
you standing your wealth your mind
and and that i i can't go with the white
privilege you know
i've been kicked [ __ ] out of themselves
before newcastle
i've been stopped by the police on the
streets walking home
never done anything wrong and i'm white
and there's millions of white people you
know and this is this is one of the
things you know it's not just
black people that attract badly it's
white people too
you know we're getting back to the thing
with the sawholder
when they told me when the agent said
they wanted you know
the the poem was anti-semitic and i've
gone on the aussie there to explain
about the point yeah
they said they want to talk to you so i
said wait ah i've got nothing to hide
i'll talk to them and
so i phoned them up we had this like
three-way conversation me the director
the programmer
and i i explained what i've explained to
you
you know and uh and then i and then i
said to them
they said all you know about the you
know will you
you know you you took certain things out
before and blah blah blah i said yeah
i said look if that's what you want me
to do right if you want me to if you
want me to take out
that line because they were they kept on
stretching that you know we can't
be seen offending people and we can't do
this and i said like okay if you don't
want to offend people right i said
i will take out that that line just
pause there for one second
yeah just for one second these are
people who run
a comedy theater yeah
and their primary concern in dealing
with you after you sold out a run to
standing ovations last year
is they don't want to offend people yeah
well that's that's what they said they
said we know we can't be seen to be
offending people and we have to be
diverse and so on and so forth and i
said
right okay i'll take out that
i'll take out that section but i said
but like i did before
when i took the piss when you censored
me before
i'll take the piss this time and this is
great and then they said
we would like we'd like you to speak to
this jewish lady
right and she used to be the creative
director of the theater
and i said wait that's fine i'll i'll do
that
you know i i wanted to
you know not because i want endorsement
from the the jewish
community but you could always call me
up mate
i'll give you a free pass yeah well
that's worth shooting do all the
holocaust jokes you want me
unfortunately you're not you're not in
the position to put me in the saw thing
that is unfortunate but she used to be
the creative director of the soho yeah
i think she she was the director of the
london jewish museum
and i wanted to talk to her not because
i said i wanted an endorsement from the
jewish community but i just wanted to
to to smooth the waters to say look
you know i know that i know it was
almost like the
they wanted me to be educated you know
in what what that reference meant
but really when i think about it that
was like so condescending once again
because i understood
the anti-semitic trope of jewish banking
and everything i understood that already
but what they didn't understand and what
they weren't prepared to be educated in
[Music]
is that working class mentality children
that doesn't understand how one of the
richest banking families in the world
and it's got nothing to do with the
being jewish just the fact that
multi-billionaires they must be able in
some way
to affect currency or stock market so
how did that conversation go with her
well that never happened
because because we we all left the
the phone call it was uh me the the
director and the programmer
it was brilliant and then and then um
they said right we'll sort the the phone
call out and
mike lee who's my agent for
acting and for uh literary things i mean
he's jewish
he's a member of the campaign against
anti-semitism
right he was going to sit in on the
conversation
right he was emailing and i was emailing
the promoter was email we're all
emailing nothing and then they came back
not last thursday but
uh thursday before when the promoter for
meetings i got some bad news for you i
said what's up lee and he said well
[Music]
you know they're dropping here they
don't want you
and now uh do you wanna is
i was disappointed but i wasn't hurt i
wasn't more or less
expecting it because i knew i just you
get a feeling doing it yeah i'm not
psychic but i mean i got you you've got
to feel i got a feeling about it
and i just thought myself nah
i can't go with that one you know and um
i mean so why do you think that happened
because it's the same show yeah you've
already done this show at the theater
yeah right
so if they're concerned about offending
people the show's the same yeah
theater's the same
so what's happened in between well like
i said because somebody had alerted the
fact that this line was
anti-semitic and everything else so when
they watched the show they were fine but
the moment someone on social media
alerted them to it
i don't see i don't know who alerted
them so i don't know i mean maybe
i don't know maybe maybe i've got an
enemy up there or somebody who was
jealous or whatever
you know and and said what do you think
about this i don't i don't know
i don't know that's that's that's out of
my control
right but it was the exact same show
they've got four standard innovations
and suddenly they said it was offensive
and and like mike lee as i say he's
jewish himself he
they phoned him up and he said well
chris was going to take that part out
and replace it with something else and
they came back and said yeah but
but the poem the right to hear
is out there online and it's gone viral
to millions of people all around the
world so you are
you are untouchable now because the poem
is out there
you can't do a show at the theater
because the poem is out there even if
you don't do it
i i don't i don't know that i don't i
don't know if it's just the poem or if
it's
if the if the poem is is has destroyed
things but you see that when the
i can't i can't describe to you right
i wrote this thing when i wrote the
right to here
it was in 2017 right i woke up one
morning
our last was going to work and i was
just like laid in bed touching myself
off right trying to
get back just trying to get back to
sleep anyhow
i went downstairs made a cuppa right got
some biscuits come back up the stairs
got back into bed right and i just i
always have
some paper and a pen next to the bed
because i don't know why i get my best
inspiration when i'm sleeping
when i wake up i've got this line you
tell me what i can't see
and i'm not i i [ __ ] you not right
tell me what i can't see it and that was
it was off
i wrote that poem in about four minutes
and it just wouldn't stop
right until i finished and when i
finished i realized
it was finished and i put it online
in 2018 after edinburgh because i used
it in the northern monkey show
which is also critically acclaimed great
show yeah right and so
and so people had seen it we didn't do
much on
online then 2019 this ex-special forces
fellow from newcastle
he'd seen it on youtube shared it to his
facebook page and all of a sudden it
started to go through the roof
and in two weeks he had about 850 000
views which is great just before i was
going to edinburgh
right with me we show forgiveness in
2019.
and then of course last year i don't
know why all of a sudden
overnight it had like 600 thousand views
and then it was like a million
and a half and then facebook
facebook sort of like is it shadow
bandit or something like this
and there was no movie so i went outside
the blast furnace again because i filmed
it the original one upside the blast
verse an albeit a slug
and i filmed it again i brought up
brought it up to date
and i clarified a clarified because in
the original it's uh it doesn't
mention the the thing about the
rothschilds being multi-billionaires but
i thought right i'll clarify that point
i'll put that point in you know what i
mean
and clarify that people know that it's
not coming from like an anti-semitic
place i'm just coming
from a fact of how can these people who
are multi-billionaires not be able to
have
you know able to affect banks i
clarified it i updated it
and that just flew i mean isaiah
washington in
america famous actor he got all of it it
was all over his instagram
i had people teachers professors from
italy
saying can we teach this to our students
in in class
tens of millions of people i had people
in in morocco
i had people in israel i had people in
nigeria
and ghana south africa all over europe
america was just like like wildfire
canada everywhere scandinavia the whole
world
right and i was like
well emotional again because i'm
i'm just like a normal working class
blog and it was too much for me to
[ __ ] take in general
like like like the it was it's so
intense
to understand what i'm saying yeah like
it was like
what the [ __ ] i felt frightened i felt
intimidated
i felt as i was in like a fishbowl and
everybody was looking at me you know i
mean
and then i had this idea i thought
myself right i could
i could do this using all these people
so we did a global version
and and i did it i mean i i don't have a
computer
don't have anything like that so i made
this video
the right to hit global version using
150
odd people from around the world from
nigeria and kenya and
ghana and south america peru
argentina brazil everywhere right
i did it all on my mobile phone they
sent me they sent me lines to the point
on my mobile phone
and i sent them to this guy it was like
a filmmaker
and he put them all together and we put
the we put the finished version
out there and it didn't do as much as
the the original
i thought was better you know even the
the the part where
you know about the rothschilds like
jewish people
did those parts did those lines you know
and so it's become the poem has become a
global phenomena
and i never expected that i didn't
intend it i didn't ask for it i didn't
ask for the attention
i get like thousands of people sending
me friend requests all the time and i
think well what you
i'm not famous i'm not a star you know i
mean i haven't got no money
i'm on the verge of going under you know
i don't have any possessions in my house
or the house i sleep and i have a chair
and a bed that's it
i don't feel worthy of this attention do
you remain
but the attention is there now and
because the attention is there
the theater turned on to the promoter
and said
on my agent mike lee and said well it
doesn't matter because he's out there
online
and i i mean i i've always been a
fighter not in terms of like physically
but like with my wits i fight my wits
you know when i when i fought the
local authority in red car of the issue
of the corrupted house in the state you
know i fought with my wits
and i thought myself well what am i
going to do with you and i have to do
something to fight back
and uh and so i just put
the post on my facebook page just in
basically i've been banned by the
theater and i couldn't believe it and
nobody else could believe it really
because it'd already been in there and
done
right massive things and i mean let me
ask you again though
why do you think that's happened i i is
there something well from what i can
gather it can be
it the decision came from above
the director of the theater i think they
might have a board or a
you know a group that controls it here i
don't know
i don't know but i think that's where
where it came from i think there are
forces at work
without being a conspiracy theorist
but i mean you know that's why i'm i'm
grateful to you guys
for inviting me on the program so like i
can
[Music]
like put my side forward publicly
because
hey listen right i mean the show never
had one complain
everywhere it's gone it's outstanding
aversions
everywhere yep when i was in the zoho
last year
and there was a an actor there from
downton abbey
he said i've never seen anything like it
people were queuing up to hug me
it set people on the road to forgiveness
themselves all the people who suffered
murder
have seen the short and it set them on
the road to forgiveness and not just
like
people have been set in the road to
forgiveness not just with
not just with big things but with little
things
one block said ellen spoke to his dad
for 10 years
and uh over and out in the summit really
and he said he's going to phone his dad
and ask me to go for a beer when i was
in edinburgh there was a girl
she was outside the theater and she was
like looking and i was giving the flyers
out
and she said oh i should come in and try
to tell her what the show was about she
said oh no it's about she said
my brother committed suicide like you
know so okay then
she i don't know whether to come in or
not it might not be for me i said well
it might be for you
i said just come in i said well there's
no ask if you don't want to come in
so anyway you know you're saying with
edinburgh
you you only got so many so many so much
time
outside leaflet and so i
i cut off time i went down into the room
got the room was packed out
about to start and all of a sudden the
door opened
this girl said came
came out of the door i said come on
idlov come on in
she sat down and she [ __ ] loved it
the show the biggest thing
for the show for me
last year in the soho theater see i've
always wanted to bring both sides of
comedy together
as i said because i think it's too top
every right
but you had middle class progressive
people
sat alongside working class people
and they were all laughing and they were
all thinking
whether they agreed or not together
and after the show and this is the
biggest compliment
that i took away from that show
was that the promoters staff came to see
i think on the thursday night and
they're all
young trendy uber progressive
you know young kind of liberal people
and they were all blown away by it
and they said it crosses so many divides
brings down so many barriers like you
know
it's promoting peace and tolerance
and and laughter and
forgiveness most of all forgiveness
never had one complaint
and so ashore that's done that
you know that yeah uses
uncompromising language in context with
the times that it was set in
right it's basically
now being put into a position whereby
we're struggling to get it out there
like because i mean
the promoter said like if if pandemic if
the pandemic hadn't happened
the promoter said if we'd had gone at
the saw theater back by popular demand
you would have had a tour generation
without question
with any question at all you're on the
tour but now we're struggling
to even find a venue for it to go in
which is a real shame it is because i'll
tell you why
right because i mean i'm on facebook all
the time it's the only thing i have to
occupy myself
and apart from doing writing my poems
and and trying
i i don't write comedy anymore because i
haven't got the outlet for it
so there's no point in frustrating
myself i mean i do write comedy every
now and again but
not like i used to and i and i look at
it and we are so
divided now in in
is i mean not just the thing with race
right
not just the thing with race but but
with this whole thing with the pandemic
it was divided by those who were afraid
of corvid 19
and those are unafraid of corvid 19
those who want to wear masks those who
don't want to wear masks
those who've been vaccinated those who
don't want to be vaccinated and it's
like i mean just coming down here on the
train it's like
like this all the time as soon as you
see anything jumping because i'm not if
you want to get the vaccine
or get jabbed have it right but don't
don't tell me that i have to have it i
mean i felt that broken today because
i mean my world has got smaller and
smaller and smaller to the point
now where basically i sit in the car all
day in this in this car park next to
this baker's in mask
near where i live and i sit there eating
cake and drinking tea and writing that's
that's how small my life's got so i and
i don't see anybody for most of the day
so like um i you know i i don't have to
provide any like vaccine passport or
anything like that right but like i am
medically exempt from ever wearing a
mask and from having the vaccine on the
job because
uh a medical audition is pre-existing
medical conditions i have
and i was getting me back together and i
thought myself i better take them
letters
you know from the doctor saying i was
exempt and that brought that brought my
heart because
for me that's like that's like a really
tough totalitarian regime isn't it
where it's like shows your purpose to do
this you know
shows your purpose to do that and
you know i put that on on facebook
coming down on the train and people say
oh yeah we live in london we never did i
said
you missed the point you missed the
point the point is right
that i felt as though i had to take
proof
of my medical status in case i was
refused entry to somewhere
it's a [ __ ] it's like it's it's like
[ __ ]
mental
i'm going somewhere tomorrow and i got
an email and they said
like have you been double jabbed you
know because
and i said no i haven't i'm medically
exempt but you know
and i think what is going on you know
where where
where are we going with all of this you
know it's a very very interesting point
there's a question that i really want to
ask you
your show is about forgiveness i watched
it it was
brilliant it was powerful it was
haunting it was incredibly funny as well
it was a perfect show
and you talked about that particular
subject looking at what's happened to
you
looking what's happening in society do
you think we're losing the ability to
forgive chris
massively sure
i told you i was going to cry my
emotions with this are all over the
place
and and it's not showboating or anything
like that
i'm walking around with this inside all
the time and that's why i appreciate you
guys inviting me down
we are all being set against each other
right
all of us right
black and white different religions
the prestiger the [ __ ] up constantly
right they're like they're like the
schoolyard bullyanna
do you mean he said he can have you or
he shouldn't love you you know oh yeah
yeah
and the next thing everybody's fighting
and the school bully [ __ ] off
or makes money in this case yeah yeah
exactly and what it requires is both
sides to get all of the school bully and
knock his [ __ ] head off you know
that's what it requires we're all being
set against each other the whole
the whole thing and and i said
i said to the people at the theater i
said you know the message
of forgiveness and and the themes of the
show
right are never more needed
than now you know and i'm not saying
that because i'm trying to sell a show
or whatever
i just think that they are
and forgiveness is a very very personal
thing
it felt right for me minority might not
feel like you might not feel right for
him
but it felt right for me jeremy
but if we can go somewhere to forgiving
you know if i've upset anybody
because of this poem i've explained the
thing forgive me
you know you can see i hope you can see
i'm not a bad block
there's no there's no malice in me and
this is one of the things i said well i
said i don't eat them
if i don't hear the man who strangled
my dad's life away and set him on fire
why would he i.e anybody because they
were black
or because they were asian or because
they were jewish or because they were
gay or whatever i wouldn't you just
wouldn't
you know and we um but in this country
in this world
it it it it's become like a really mean
place and i've seen that get worse over
the last
18 months you know it's it it's become
like a [ __ ] bear pit hasn't it jeremy
it's like a dog fight social media when
you said about do you go on twitter i
don't go on twitter because he's too
much of a toxic place and never knows
first box of talks i mean facebook's bad
enough but twitter is terrible
you know but yeah we we do we do lack
forgiveness
so much and you know not just from
from a viewpoint of me wanting to
to get get recognition or
or get something for myself through the
show i think
it's a message of the show that i want
to take out there
you know because i've seen the power of
it i've seen
the power of the show somebody said to
me it's one of the best comedy shows
that i've that i've ever seen and
they're like a uh
like top er person and um
and when you get like some of the
critics saying the things that they've
said about it
then you know that it means something
it's an important it's an important show
i don't know it being the best show or
the funniest show whatever but it's one
of the most important shows
you know as a whole because it
conference and takes on so many
tackles so many issues all in the thing
of my
father's murder chris
it's been an incredible interview thank
you so much thank you very much
we always end our interviews with one
question
it's always what's the one thing we're
not talking about
but we really should be class
class stop discriminating
against working working-class people no
matter what color they are
class don't be embarrassed about
everybody gets about oh you know
the sideways mcdonough huh someone you
mentioned class oh [ __ ] people
hurry you're up stephanie mcgovern
from middle school middlesbrough this
used to be the bbc's
uh business correspondent i think
she said in the guardian when she went
for a interview for the bbc she did
brilliantly and this guy came over and
said oh that was fantastic you know we
didn't think people like you were
intelligent
and you want to know what it was they
saw when the soho theater took the show
they said oh you know they came from the
promotion he said
they really want you because they
believe in diversity
they're believing can you believe that i
mean i put that in the show
they want you because they believe in
diversity
right so and i'll say this uncertainly
because we are
white working class people are the
biggest social democratic
in this country right
but now the regard white working class
people
right as basically a minority
it's [ __ ] incredible it is incredible
and and you know and not you saw what
happened at the football match it's a
minority with the european
uh championship final it's a minority
minority but but they're trying to
they're trying to desperately tar
a whole class a whole culture
with that racist brush and it's wrong
and they're trying to rob us of our
culture
of our mentality of who we are
of what we were a perhaps even what we
want to become
because we never we never get out
looking you tell me any
any facet of our society that detail
that is run by a working class person
i mean even the labor party i mean the
labour party
if if that doesn't show you how much
working-class people are discriminated
against
if you had a black community group that
was run by a white person that'd be
alone
if you had a gay community group that
was run by a straight person of beyond
if you had a muslim group that was run
by a christian to be alone right or
another religion like if it was indoors
run by a jew or whatever it would be
alone right
in effect the labor party
is a working class community group
and it's run by middle-class progressive
people
and that's why the working class has
said
[ __ ] you because there's a massive
disconnect there
and what they think and believe or run
in the labour party
isn't what we think and believe and
that's why at the by-election in may
nightly poll right
for the first time in 57 years my whole
life
the people of agripola returned atari mp
and when you think about it right
when you think about it we expect to be
[ __ ] on by the tories
we expect that but we don't expect to
have
our own [ __ ] on us and we don't expect
our own to look down the [ __ ] noises
as
jonah maine and that's what we're
getting
let's talk about class shall we let's
have a working class leader of the labor
party
i'm up for the job chris thanks for
coming on
my pleasure i've loved every single
second we've loved having you and
you know you and i go back a few years
now i've watched
everything you've done i'm very proud of
you thank you i'm so proud of you you've
done incredibly well
to break through to get to where you are
and i hope that people who see this
interview
i hope something good comes out of it i
believe in you
i believe in what you've done it was a
beautiful show that deserves to be seen
by way more people than it's been seen
by
and there's good things in the future
for you
we have we're hoping that another
theater is going to come we have
hopes for that person yeah and if
anybody out there who can
affect change wants to put it on in a
london theater
big london theater i'll be more than
grateful
where can people find you online uh
facebook
chris mcglade on facebook yeah yeah uh
twitter i go on twitter but not so much
and i i have an
instagram account but i haven't got a
[ __ ] clue what i'm doing with it so i
don't even want the portion on there you
know
yeah uh find chris on facebook uh that's
where
you can get all his uh views and comedy
and all the other stuff that he puts out
chris thanks for coming on my pleasure
we we're going to do some questions for
locals as well thank you
uh but thank you for watching and
listening we will see you very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one
or raw show all of them go out at 7 pm
uk time or 2 p.m eastern standard
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry
is important support us by joining our
locals community
using the link below